[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nouveaux numéros de mode
d'emploi ce mois ci on s'intéresse à
l'emploi des jeunes suite à cette crise
sanitaire tout de suite le sommet les
jeunes font face à l'incertitude sur le
marché de l'emploi trouver une
entreprise pour son alternance ou un
travail pour l'été des démarches
compliquées par le contexte d'une
reprise de l'activité économique
progressive focus sur une session de
recrutement d'apprentis et sur la
recherche d'un travail saisonnier
l'intérim a été frappée par la crise
sanitaire btp industrie hôtellerie des
secteurs qui embauchent de nombreux
intérimaires
nous nous sommes rendu dans une agence
d'intérim pour constater les
conséquences de la crise
enfin saint quentin en yvelines organise
le summer quand numérique du 20 au 31
juillet
l'occasion pour une centaine de jeunes
de s'initier aux métiers du numérique un
événement dédié aux saint quentinois
âgés de 16 à 25 ans et on commence avec
les chiffres de pôle emploi et les faits
déconfinement sur le chômage au mois de
mai dans les yvelines le nombre de
personnes sans activité inscrits à pôle
emploi a baissé de 2 43% après une
hausse historique de 10 7% au mois
d'avril due à la crise sanitaire cette
diminution montre la reprise progressive
de l'activité
mais elle doit observer par rapport au
basculement de demandeurs d'emploi vers
des activités réduites dans les autres
catégories au total dans le département
112 mille cent personnes sont inscrites
à pôle emploi
l'impact sur l'emploi se fait ressentir
aussi sur le travail temporaire la crise
sanitaire n'a pas épargné l'intérim une
diminution de 70% de l'activité
intérimaire a été constaté c'est le cas
notamment à l'âge à lagence option un
terrain situé à montigny le bretonneux
elle travaille avec une trentaine de pme
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines aujourd'hui elle est à peine à
50 % de sa capacité d'activité le
reportage de manon varaldo le marché de
l'intérim a été frappée en quelques
jours en raison de la crise sanitaire et
du confinement
c'est le cas de lagence option en terme
situées à montigny le bretonneux le
marché d'un brain vient de vivre une
chute assez catastrophique atteignant
une baisse varie entre moins 60 - 70 %
en fait
de là c'est toi la situation il faut
savoir que ce choc-là c'est ça
représente 5 à 4 à 5 fois plus que le
choc de 2008
pendant cette période les secteurs du
bâtiment et de l'industrie ont été les
plus impactés plus de 60 % de perte
d'activité pour le btp et environ 50 %
pour l'industrie
le 11 mai lagence option intérim a
rouvert les intérimaires étaient
nombreux à revenir
je vais par est de poser la question à
savoir si si vous aviez des besoins de
la semaine prochaine on a pensé que le
secteur du nettoyage
allez avoir un rebond on a pu constater
que c'était pas le cas aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas de secteur à notre niveau
kiki qui est plus avantagés par rapport
à un autre
cette crise a donc touché tous les
secteurs et engendré une perte
importante pour le fondateur de cette
société créée il ya douze ans père de
trésorerie on est on je pense à plus de
cinq cent mille euros de deux paires de
trésorerie sur un sursis sur ces trois
mois estimant de non activité
donc on est encore très loin
effectivement de nos nos chiffres de
début d'année parce qu'on avait réalisé
de vraiment un début d'année qui était
exceptionnel ce qu'on était plus de 40%
du chiffre d'affaires par rapport à et
de -1
on espère effectivement retrouvé sept
cette croissance du sis d'ici la fin de
l'année quand certains de leurs clients
n'ont pas encore repris à 100 % leurs
activités comme dans le secteur de
l'industrie ou du bâtiment
la reprise d'activité se fait
progressivement dans le secteur du
bâtiment c'est dans ce contexte que le
centre de formation aux métiers du btp
attrape à organiser courant juin
plusieurs journées de rencontres entre
les futurs apprentis et les entreprises
objectif permettre aux jeunes en
formation à la rentrée 2020 de trouver
une entreprise pour l'alternance les
images sont signés michael et demi
d'euros de travaux
on va dire et les 50% sur 150 %
sur les bases 10 avec la reprise
d'activité sur les chantiers le besoin
en main d'oeuvre se fait ressentir les
entreprises focalisent leurs
recrutements notamment sur les apprentis
c'est le cas de ce grand groupe
une quinzaine de postes en apprentissage
est proposée tous deux chantiers ont été
arrêtés du coup beaucoup de retard sur
certains de nos chantiers donc on a
besoin de main d'oeuvre et nous chez
vinci on a une force politique jeunes
aussi donc tous les ans contexte
particulier ou pas on a besoin on
recrute d'apprentis pour cette pme
spécialisée dans les canalisations
l'assainissement et l'eau potable
échantillons été reportée pendant le
confinement
les recrutements sont nécessaires pour
sa reprise d'activité on a un manque de
main d'oeuvre aujourd'hui et pour le
futur proche à des chefs de chantier ou
une manoeuvre vieillissante donc il faut
former aujourd'hui pour garder une
dynamique et conserver à voir des jeunes
pour demain l'impact des faits kévin
c'est que ça a retardé
nos chantiers de deux mois mais
aujourd'hui ce soit sur le volume il n'y
a pas eu de baisse ni d'augmentation
c'est assez osé
ces apps et bts et bac professionnel
toutes les filières du centre de
formation des métiers du btp à trappes
sont en apprentissage malgré la crise
sanitaire la structure a organisé cette
journée
objectif faciliter les rencontres entre
les entreprises et les jeunes dans le
domaine des travaux publics la demande
est forte
on a des demandes des grands groupes des
multinationales dont des agences sont
implantés dans les yvelines
et on a aussi une demande importante
des entreprises
type pme ou des entreprises artisanales
on a beaucoup craint il ya quelques mois
que les
que les demandes soient soit très limité
les grâces aussi peut-être aux aides à
l'apprentissage et puis à la confiance
que des entreprises accordent aux jeunes
la demande reste forte donc on est on
est confiant dans la recherche d'une
entreprise pour une formation en
apprentissage parfois un véritable
parcours du combattant
un sentiment renforcé par le contexte
actuel même sur le peu vide c'est
toujours compliqué de trouver une
entreprise tourne alternance c'est assez
long même si on s'y prend à cette eau on
a toujours des réponses assez lente par
rapport aussi à ce qui s'est passé au
couvent in situ c'est plus difficile
d'avoir des entretiens scellés
entretiens qu'ont fait par audiovisuel
et parfois ça n'aboutit pas vraiment
pendant la période du coc vide on n'a
pas pu se déplacer n'a pas pu postuler
et ont ensuite du mal à les joindre
près de deux cent cinq jeunes sont
formés chaque année en apprentissage au
centre de formation des métiers du btp
attrape les face aux incertitudes de la
situation économique actuelle saint
quentin en yvelines se mobilisent aussi
avec sa plateforme sky emploi.fr en plus
de répertorier les offres d'emploi et de
stage une section alternance et
apprentissage a été lancé objectif
faciliter la recherche d'une entreprise
pour les jeunes et d'un apprenti pour
les employeurs si vous vous trouvez dans
cette situation vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
c'est une idée originale pour relancer
l'emploi et créer des vocations pour les
jeunes l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines lance le sommer campe
numérique dix jours d'initiation aux
métiers du numérique entre le 20 et 31
juillet destiné aux jeunes saint
quentinois âgés de 16 à 25 ans les
détails dans ce reportage
découvrir les activités d'un développeur
web d'un community manager d'un
spécialiste en objets connectés ou en
cyber sécurité
le principe du summer camp tenu méric du
20 au 31 juillet organisé par saint
quentin en yvelines en collaboration
avec pop school et o'clock ces
structures de formation ont préparé
plusieurs ateliers
le format des ateliers va être
les pensées autour d'une progression qui
permet de s'intéresser d'abord de
manière large à différents métiers et
ensuite de restreindre le périmètre
progressivement par exemple sur le
développement web
les jaunes vont pour les jeunes vont
pouvoir développer des petits sites
internet et donc découvrir la
programmation découvrir la mise en page
des éléments sur une page web
l'interactivité destiné aux jeunes âgés
de 16 à 25 ans une centaine de personnes
pourra participer aux dix jours
d'initiation en présentiel à la
pépinière d'entreprises promo paul ou à
distance dans les missions locales ou à
la cité des métiers
objectif favoriser les emplois dans le
numérique dans un contexte de crise
économique
j'en laisse entreprise de saint quentin
en yvelines qui nous disent qu'elles ont
besoin de ses compétences là et donc on
essaie de mettre en adéquation la
demande d'emploi avec l'offre d'emploi
sur la filière du numérique nous avons 5
à 6000 emplois non pourvus sur saint
quentin en yvelines
inscription gratuite et obligatoire en
fonction des places disponibles avant le
16 juillet prochain
pendant les vacances scolaires estivales
les jeunes peuvent aussi trouver un job
d'été mais avec la crise sanitaire les
offres se font rares les secteurs de la
restauration l'hôtellerie et le tourisme
qui jouent un rôle crucial chez les
saisonniers ont été fortement impactés
yvin information jeunesse et le pôle
jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux
accompagnent les jeunes dans leurs
recherches
en ces temps difficiles un reportage de
mathilde et demi le monde agricole le
service à la personne l'hôtellerie le
tourisme ou encore la restauration sont
des secteurs qui recrutent beaucoup de
saisonniers
cette année ces secteurs ont été très
impacté par la crise sanitaire et les
offres pour un job d'été se font rares
notamment au pôle jeunesse à montigny le
bretonneux
je pense ça va être beaucoup plus dur
parce que pour les commerçants les
entreprises
la conjoncture est assez incertaine déjà
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de visibilité si
ça va reprendre l'activité va reprendre
à la normale et même s'ils vont pouvoir
garder leurs salariés par la suite donc
les besoins saisonniers seront plus
restreint après ils peuvent avoir au
bout d'un certain temps avec un surcroît
d'activité besoin de personnel
occasionnel dans les bureaux d'île une
information jeunesse tout se passe à
présent sur les réseaux sociaux pour
s'adapter à la situation des années
précédentes le mois de mai était décisif
pour trouver une offre d'emploi cette
année les offres arrivent au compte
gouttes
on a toujours travaillé sur le sur des
forums avec du dating c'est à dire des
entreprises et les jeunes depuis de
nombreuses années on avait déjà commencé
à enclencher des réunions de travail
qu'on a dû annuler puisque les forums
n'ont pas eu lieu
on a voulu éventuellement leur est
organisé en juin juillet mais en fait on
n'avait pas de retour des entreprises
donc les entreprises sont en train de
reprendre leurs actes leurs activités
mais n'ont pas tellement de visibilité
donc en fait aujourd'hui au vu du
contexte c'est maintenant que ça se
passe en fait et c'est un petit peu au
jour le jour l'année 2020 s'annonce plus
compliquée pour la recherche d'un emploi
saisonnier
il faudra patienter et rechercher
activement sur les sites plateforme et
réseaux sociaux pour espérer trouver un
job cet été ils ont beaucoup souffert
pendant le confinement mais les
restaurateurs ont repris leurs activités
depuis le mois de juin une activité
exercée dans le cadre de normes d'autant
plus importante avec la crise sanitaire
dans ce contexte marie pigné propose des
formations aux normes dans le secteur de
la restauration dirigeante de unit
formation et conseil à la créer cette
entreprise en 2018 à elancourt après 20
ans d'expérience dans ce domaine c'est
la séquence trois questions à marie
pigné
une entreprise dédiée à toute la partie
réglementation pour les dirigeants et le
personnel dans les métiers de bouche
donc nous parlons essentiellement aux
restaurateurs aux boulangers aux
bouchers donc toutes les personnes qui
manipulent des denrées andy alimentaire
nous travaillons sur trois axes comment
répondre à la réglementation et
l'hygiène donc toute la partie haccp
comment répondre à la répression des
fraudes donc tout ce qui est information
consignes aux consommateurs et comment
répondre à la réglementation ou droit du
travail durant le confinement nous on a
souhaité garder le contact avec avec nos
clients et les autres n'a organisé
environ tous les quinze jours oui nanard
pour permettre aux restaurateurs et même
aux futurs restaurateurs de pouvoir
participer et avoir des informations sur
comment s'adapter comment mettre en
place certaines choses
c'est une formation qu'on a voulu simple
abordable et puis aussi pas très longue
donc qu'elle dure sept heures on a
beaucoup de d'informations qui nous sont
parvenues donc de l'état et c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une
formation qui est complètement collés au
protocole et qui leur permet de répondre
à ce protocole dont sur toutes les
vignes comment je mets en place mon plan
de maîtrise sanitaire renforcée durant
cofide comment je vais communiquer à mai
avec les salariés pour qu'ils puissent
être partie prenante de cette nouvelle
méthodologie de travail
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivi une émission à
retrouver henry paix sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]